T Cell Activation take place when they  interact with antigen presenting cells  such as a dendritic cell  so dendritic cell present the  antigens on top of Class 2 MHC molecule  and there are three signals which are  required for T Cell Activation the TCR  MHC interaction leads to the signal one  the Siri 80 series 86 and Siri 28  present on T cells give the second  signal  and the third signal comes from the  cytokine signaling such as interleukin-2  all these three signals lead to  activation  but also there are negative core  stimulatory signals as well that  prevents the activation so in T cells  there is always a balance between  positive and negative code stimulation  that means negative regulation is also  important watch the full video to learn  more